To go over the mathematics
of both dilation and
erosion, we have to talk about something
called the structuring element, okay?
The structuring element is a mask, okay?
It's a shape that you're going
to use to do these operations.
And, it can be any shape.
For today, the shapes
are going to be ones and zeroes.
They can also be ones, zeroes, and x's.
And the x's are don't cares.
But nothing we're going to talk about
today will, will involve don't care, so
I'm not going to talk about it.
What's important about the shape is that
they all are defined with respect to
sometimes called an anchor, or
reference point, or an origin, right?
And usually, not always,
usually that origin is in the middle
of whatever shape you're making use of,
okay?
So given a structuring element,
we can define both dilation and erosion.
So dilation is as follows.
Basically, I've got some binary image,
B, okay?
And that's here.
I've got a structuring element, S.
And the structuring element
has to have an origin.
Basically, what you do is,
you're going to take this
dilation structuring element and
you're going to run it around here,
placing the origin at different places.
And wherever you place it,
you're going to take the OR
of all of the ones in the structuring
element with the ones underneath it.
And so what that means is if any of the
ones land, of the structuring element,
land on a one in the binary image,
the aura of all that will be one.
So, Arpin did this and he's very proud.
So, there's my structure element, and
he, there he goes, [SOUND] very good.
Cool.
All right?
So you basically run it all over, and
what the result of this, okay,
is this val, is thing here.
And let's just take a lot at that,
right?
These are our two original ones.
Okay.
So when I put this structuring element
down here, like that, nothing was a one.
In fact, as I slide it all along,
nothing is a one, so
those are all zeroes.
Right?
But when I put my structuring element
here, notice it overlaps there.
Okay.
So this value which is the origin for
that first position, that gets a one.
And as I slide it along, that's how
I get the, the, the rest of these.
So that's dilation by
a particular shape.
Now I'll tell you
sometimes you'll dilate by
sort of a funny shape like that.
Usually your shape will be symmetric.
Sometimes it will be
taller than it is wide
because you're trying to extend things
in one direction as opposed to another.
But this cutout kind of thing
would be a little bit unusual.
In fact, here's a nice example.
So here's a binary text and you can see
that there's white pixels but they've
got lots of, if, you know, if you take
a look at that m, you can see it's
kind of, bunch of little spots in there
that seem to have some holes in it.
So if I use a structuring
element that looks like this.
That, essentially, says that if I touch
anybody to my right, left, up or, or
below, I want to turn on the pixel.
And, when I do that, you get
the really much better result, right?
I mean, it's much easier to read the one
on the left, the one on the right.
The one on the right might be uglier,
okay, because it doesn't look so
crisp, but
there's no question about reading it.